[Music]
hmm
[Music]
i want to show you two sequences that if
you're only given a few terms
they are really hard they both appeared
in eureka in this magazine in their
puzzle section
the the first one i can do without
cheating and it goes like this
three four six
eight uh
nine ten no eleven now twelve
yeah twelve thirteen
fourteen i've already given you more
than
the eureka puzzle gave you so what's the
formula
there's a very simple formula but you
really won't guess it
it's really annoying this you can see
why i hate these puzzles
if they only give you a few terms let's
subtract one and we get
2 3 5 7
11 13 the primes
so this sequence it goes up by one then
it goes up by two and two and four
oh and then two and so on it looks like
it's something to do with adding twos
but in fact subtract one and it becomes
transparent this is the kind of thing
where even if you say yes all right
there are mil
but there are a million ways to extend
the sequence to explain the sequence
but when you see the the answer the the
this is a good puzzle
in the sense that it's puzzling and yet
when you see the answer
you're you say all right yes i admit
that's what the answer has to be
so these were the the primes plus one
basically yes that's all
okay i'm going to come up with my own
sequence on that just make it the primes
plus eight or something and
yeah you could certainly just as hard
harder because it probably isn't in the
oais
there's a related one and now i can do
it without cheating it goes like this
five eight uh
12 18 24.
now you look at that and you say well
look there we've got 6 times 2 6 times 3
6 times 4
and then there are a couple of
experimental errors at the beginning
basically this is going to be multiples
of six right
wrong you want a chance to think about
it
all right okay back in the room back in
the room
here's the answer let me change these
commas to pluses
two plus three three plus five
five plus seven seven plus eleven it's
the sums
of two consecutive primes isn't that
annoying
and yet when you see it it's clearly the
right answer
so when you're given one of these
puzzles
on a quiz or an iq test or a job
interview or something
the first thing you should do is excuse
yourself
go to the bathroom and look it up in the
oeis
do you want to learn more about primes
or maybe just numbers in general
well today's episode sponsor is
brilliant a resource
jam packed with quizzes puzzles and
courses that are not only
fun but designed to make you that little
bit smarter
i particularly enjoy doing these daily
challenges
they always make me smile but the
courses like these
they're the main meals on brilliant
you're always going to find something
appealing across a full range of
mathematics and science
if you're already using brilliant you
can also consider maybe
giving it as a gift to learn more give
it a try
go to brilliant.org number file the
address there on the screen
using that slash number file has the
bonus effect of giving you a 20
discount on a premium subscription
16 steps it must it gets stuck
it cannot move every square of every one
of the eight squares around it that it
could move to
it's already been to so it die the
sequence dies